teeth are like one of my biggest
turn-ons yeah you heard that right
nothing gets Kim Kardashian in the mood
like a good set of chompers
but not kidding Kim opens up about her
turn-ons on the latest episode of Hulu's
the Kardashians revealing the surprising
physical trait that really rubs her
engine teeth are like one of my biggest
turn-ons the straighter the hornier okay
of course Kim and her ex Kanye West
finalize their divorce last November
after six years of marriage and
following their split she dated Pete
Davidson he's just super genuine I love
the chemistry that Kim and him have
together it's really sweet I thought you
said the chemistry I was like okay
chemistry chemistry but the two called
it quits in August after nine months of
dating and now Kim is manifesting her
next great love man list
a manifest list no really guys she made
a list of all the things she's looking
for in a partner I don't know what's
gonna top that number one protect me
number two fight for me number three
good hygiene I mean that's like a given
I think I should even take that off
number four calm five no mom or dad
issues six patient seven supportive
genuinely happy for me successful good
teeth yeah yeah yeah we know all about
the teeth thing Kim yeah Bible it's a
great look spontaneous fun my friends
and family love him someone that can be
a role model for my kids especially that
my boys can look up to no heavy baggage
I have enough taller than me someone
that loves to work out a motivated
person an independent person that's not
clingy and someone with good taste no
balding
but then I don't know if I was like if
I'm also in love like I'll rub your bald
head Kim's been making all kinds of
candid confessions lately it's a lot on
a previous episode of the famous
family's reality series Kim revealed how
she sets the mood in the bedroom so
weird but then I can like walk out of a
photo shoot with like a hundred people
working on set I can walk out like in a
thong but if it's like you're there with
me I'm like wait
turn the lights off as for Love A source
told E.T last month that Kim's laid back
about dating is in no rush to meet
someone and is comfortable being single
Kim's just living her best life and
isn't taking herself too seriously I
swear I'm really good she has amazing
energy right now and everyone around her
loves it cheers Kim to finding your
perfect partner May the floss be with
you teeth are like one of my biggest
turn-ons the straighter the hornier okay